so we have something interesting going
on I have this ring of conductor right
here the square ring it has a resistance
of 2 ohms we see that it is 2 meters by
2 meters so the area of this ring would
be 4 square meters and we see a magnetic
field going through the surface defined
by the ring and it's constant it's a
constant magnetic field of five Tesla's
it's going exactly perpendicular ly to
perpendicularly to the surface of the
Ring now what we're going to happen what
we're going to see happen is over the
next 4 seconds and this is going to
happen at a linear rate it's going to
happen at a constant rate we're going to
see the magnetic field over 4 seconds go
from five Tesla's to 10 Tesla so it's
going to double over those 4 seconds and
by doing so we're going to have a change
in flux let's think about what the
change in flux is over this 4 seconds so
our initial flux let me write it over
here so flux we're just a different
color and at any time if you are so
inspired I encourage you to pause the
video and figure out what our change in
flux is so our flux flux initial is
going to be well it's the it's going to
be the constant magnetic field you could
say the average magnetic field over the
surface but since it's constant that's
just going to be five Tesla's so five
Tesla's and it helps for it helps us in
this problem that the magnetic field
vectors are exactly perpendicular to the
surface to the surface defined by the
ring if they weren't we would have to
find the component that is perpendicular
but we have that right over there so we
have five Tesla's that's the average
magnetic field or the average component
of the magnetic field that is
perpendicular to the surface so five
Tesla's times the area of the surface so
times well 2 meters times 2 meters is 4
square meters so that is going to be
equal to and that is equal to 20 Tesla
meter squared
Tesla meters squared fair enough now
what's the final what's the final flux
the final flux flux final is going to be
equal to well now
now the average magnetic field or the
the average components of the magnet
field that are perpendicular in the way
I've defined this magnetic field the
vectors are already perpendicular is 10
Tesla's to 10
Tesla's the area of our of our ring
hasn't changed so still four square
meters so times four square meters and
so what is this going to be so our time
our final flux is going to be final flux
is going to be forty forty Tesla meters
squared so what is our what is our
change in flux let me write this over
here our change in flux change in flux
which is going to be our final flux
minus our initial flux is going to be
forty Tesla meter squared minus 20 Tesla
meter squared which is just going to be
20 Tesla meter squared so we figured out
the change in flux we actually know the
change in time it's going to be four
seconds and actually using that we can
now figure out what the voltage induced
is going to be the voltage induced to
which or the voltage that's going to now
induce induce a current and if you look
up Faraday's law on the internet you
look up for a formula for Faraday's law
you would see something that looks like
this UT voltage generated is equal to
negative and at least if you're not
using the calculus version of it
negative n times our change in flux
change in write change in flux and that
just flux change in flux Delta flux over
change in time so one way to think about
this and to do this problem right we're
assuming we have the constant or the
rate of change is constant in our flux
so you have the average rate of change
of your flux and then you're going to
multiply it times n n is actually the
number of loops you have or you can
think of it the number of surfaces
defined by it in this exact example in
this exact example n is just going to be
one we just have one loop so that
simplifies it right over there and then
so this is going to be and you might say
what is this negative because it's
a bit of a strange thing because you
know how are we defining direction you
know what didn't it and all of that and
that's why I'm a little bit I'm not a
huge fan of this negative sign this is
you know if you look it up on in a
textbook they'll often say and you're
not using calculus they'll say oh this
reminder to use lenses law they'll write
literally lenses law when I would say if
they want a reminder to use lenses law
why don't they just remind you to use
lenses law instead of putting a a kind
of bizarre negative sign there and the
negative sign actually does make sense
if you're if you were doing kind of the
the using the vectors here and and
taking the and and using a little bit of
the well doing more sophisticated
mathematics but this is just saying that
the voltage induced is going to be in a
direction so to induce a current who's
who's induced magnetic field will go in
the direction will will counteract the
change in flux so that's just lenses law
there so the real key here is at least
for this example is to find our change
in flux over change in time our average
or average rate of change in flux and
what is this going to be well this is
going to be twenty Tesla meters squared
twenty Tesla meters squared that was our
change in flux right over there
divided by our change in time which is
four seconds over four seconds which is
going to be equal to and I could throw
that negative there if we want to that
negative 20 divided by four is five five
Tesla meter squared square meters per
second and this actually turns out to be
a volt so we could say this is negative
five volts
negative negative five volts negative
five volts so if you have a voltage of
well let's just say five volts we can
think about the negative later if you
have a voltage of five volts across a
car across a circuit that has a
resistance of two ohms
what is the current and what is the
current going to be but we just have to
remind ourselves V is equal to I R or
voltage is equal to the current divided
by the voltage is equal to the current
times the resistance or you could say
that the current the current is
equal to the voltage divided by the
resistance so in this case the current
the current induced is going to be the
voltage and I'm just going to focus on
its absolute value now we can think
about its direction in a second it's
going to be its voltage five volts
divided by the resistance so two ohms
two ohms which is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to two point
five two point five amperes two point
five amperes so we now know the
magnitude of the current that's going to
be induced while we have this change in
flux remember this is going to happen
while over the course of this four
seconds as we have this rate of change
of flux this average rate of change of
flux which we'll assume is the actual
rate of change of flux we're assuming
that we it's it's changing at a constant
rate and so while it is changing we were
just able to figure out that it would
induce a current of two point five
amperes now the next question we should
ask ourselves and this is where this
little negative comes in is a reminder
for us to use lens's laws well which
direction is that current going to go in
is it going to go in let me pick two
orientations is it going to go in a is
it going to go in a in a clockwise
direction is it going to go that way
over the course of this change in flux
or it's going to go into a
counterclockwise direction is it going
to go that way and to think about that
we just have to use the right hand rule
take our right hand point our thumb in
the direction of the the proposed
direction of the current and so if we
went with this one our right hand our
right hand would look like this I'm
literally taking my left hand out and
I'm a high right hand out and I'm
drawing it and I'm looking at it to
think about what would happen so that's
my right hand so if I use the right hand
rule if the current went in this
direction then it would induce a
magnetic field that went that went like
this and so if the current went in this
direction the magnetic field it induces
inside the surface would only reinforce
the change in flux so it would only add
to the flux so and it's going in the
same direction as the change in flux
which would just keep us you know as we
talked about it if you in the Lenz's law
video that would turn into justice the
source of
energy that comes out of nowhere and
defies the law of conservation of energy
so this absolutely not is not going to
be the direction and so we know that the
direction is going to be in a clockwise
one so the current the 2 point 5 ampere
current is going to flow is going to
flow like that and we're done by
thinking about our change in flux and
how long it's taking us we were able to
figure out not only the magnitude of the
current we're able to figure out the
orientation of the direction that is
actually going to flow in